hi i'm dee
i just wanted to know what was the
shittiest day job that you've ever
had that inspired you to want to
at least you know because we wanted to
like be successful and wealthy and
famous like the one that you really
despised
the cities shittiest day job i ever had
which i literally had for a day
i was fired at the end of the day
is i was a telephone sales person
for uh time life books it was and and uh
you know i was in a room with like 20
other sales people and we
they gave us lists of phone numbers to
call when we were trying to sell
uh these time life books and we had a
script
that we were supposed to stick to and of
course
you know so you're calling up people you
know hi mrs smith uh you know i'm george
from time life books uh
we're offering a special premium here on
our book about the mysteries of the sea
and at that point you know the person
would usually hang up
and i would have to call the the next
person and uh you know they would hang
up etc
occasionally people would just say [ __ ]
you
get lost uh you know why are you
bothering me or something like that
um and that does that was all bad uh so
what did you do to get fired from that
well i didn't sell any books
oh they went by and i might so you know
every time you sold the book you had to
go to the front and put like a star
up next to your name and you had to get
to the bottom of the script i mean
ideally
you wanted like the person to say
nothing
and you get through this whole script
and then at the end it was like the last
question is
so mrs smith shall i put you down for
your copy it's only 9.95
and you know then you would put her down
and they would get a copy and a bill for
9.95 you know but sometimes you got
people i mean in addition to the [ __ ]
use and the
hang-ups you would get like old people
who
were desperate to talk you know
then you'd be on the phone for ages with
uh
oh that sounds very nice i always like
fish
i'm glad that you like fish mrs smith uh
the mystery of the sea has a lot of fish
in it
and you'd be doing that or you know and
and the script is like they trained you
that no matter what they said
you you were supposed to go back
to the script you know you you had to
had to
you know and when i i i'm sorry i don't
read i can't read i never passed reading
well
there are many there's many fine
pictures
in the mysteries of the sea and there's
pictures of
fish and uh
you know whales uh you know do you like
whales
buy the book and i'll read it for you
i'm sorry but i have cancer well i'm
sorry you have cancer mrs smith but uh
um there are octopuses
it was a pretty horrible job and i was
you know very
very glad when i got fired from that job
at the end
i'm sorry i wrapped my head around
picturing you as a real estate agent
yes well i'm glad i avoided that one i
never actually did that one